у крему хотів би сказати ще ми починаємо
у реформувати систему провтикав світла
ще й дуже важливо
як тисяч на простих а святого миколи в
жити і ніхто системно спрямований
займався знижки повз нього такі
результати до мого у нас сьогодні по
проблема в рівних спеціальність
технічних спеціальностей на знімає
трактори німа
монтажники в шва че ти хто реально
проти і в реальному секти і дуже
важливо ще до системи про завжди
технічного світла було адекватним і по
досвіду на ринку пройти гру то вала
якості кваліфікації до та й за раз
обраного ти професії міністерством
усвяти
нехай будуть рівні ноги і навчальний
програми так ми зможемо можуть уват і
конкретних конкретних потреб потреб ринку
пахових та окисних кадри для українських
підприємств